[Musica]
[Applauso]
e davvero possibile viaggiare nel tempo
sicuramente voi vi starete stupendo di
questa domanda poi proprio fatta da un
astrofisico e perché ve lo sto chiedendo
potreste avere un atteggiamento un po
spaventato o forse un atteggiamento di
esaltazione o potreste rimanere del
tutto indifferenti ma io ve lo sto
raccontando perché amo la fisica e
perché amo le sfide e allora guardiamo
questa storia e cominciamo a conoscere i
protagonisti di questa storia se sono a
napoli e voglio andare a milano posso
dire che per raggiungere milano devo
fare 600 chilometri e per raggiungere
roma
mi devo fare 200 ma se ho una macchina
che va a 100 chilometri orari
io posso anche dire qualcos'altro posso
dire che milano dista da me sei ore e
che in realtà napoli dista da me due ore
questo è se vado con una macchina che va
a 100 chilometri orari ma se invece una
navicella fotonica se sto andando alla
velocità della luce che cosa sto facendo
bene
se sto andando alla velocità della luce
sto viaggiando a 300 mila chilometri
orari
e allora cosa dico della distanza della
luna dalla terra
potrei dire che è 380.000 km ma potrei
anche dire che è 1,27 secondi e il sole
beh il sole sono ben 150 milioni di
chilometri oppure 8 minuti e marte marte
la nostra nuova frontiera 252 milioni e
600 mila chilometri o 14 minuti
attenzione però 14 minuti con la mia
navicella fotonica
in realtà le navicelle che abbiamo né a
disposizione solo un po più lenta
se proprio volesse andare a scattare la
lui la fotografia su marte con la
maggiore velocità che posso comunque
impiegherei otto mesi allora spostiamoci
usciamo fuori dal nostro sistema solare
arriviamo alle stelle la nostra stella
più vicina
proxima centauri bene proxima centauri
di stan tanto 40.000 miliardi di
chilometri oppure 4,2 anni luce e
andiamo ancora più lontani ci stiamo
avvicinando alle galassie
queste sono due galassie che stanno nel
sud sono due galassie che chiamiamo le
nubi di magellano bene queste due dubbi
distano rispettivamente 160 mila e 200
mila chilometri e duecento mila anni
luce ma quando la luce è partita proprio
da queste due galassie sulla terra in
realtà noi avevamo i primati e questo
invece cos'è questo è un ammasso di
galassie è un ammasso di galassie che
dista 240 milioni di anni luce e cioè
quando la luce partita da questo ammasso
di galassie sulla terra c'erano i
dinosauri
abbiamo parlato quindi di distanza di
tempo di luce ma come è stato il
percorso che ha fatto questa luce finora
parlando di distanza di tempo abbiamo
ipotizzato che la luce si muovesse
secondo una linea retta si muove sempre
secondo una linea retta non sempre non
sempre perché se lungo il suo percorso
la nostra luce incontra un ostacolo in
realtà questa viene deviata e allora
immaginate che questo reticolo sia un
lenzuolo
se sul lenzuolo non c'è niente la luce
va in linea retta
ma se sul lenzuolo certo una massa
questa massa deforma il nostro lenzuolo
e quindi la luce che noi vediamo partire
da a a e la posizione reale della stella
per arrivare sulla terra fa una piccola
curva una curva che dipende da quanto il
lenzuolo è stato deformato e cioè in
modo apparente a noi la stella sembra
essere in b perché noi ipotizziamo che
il nostro percorso della della luce sia
per linea retta ma non è così e quindi
einstein
già nella sua relatività generale ci
aveva parlato della possibilità che la
la la materia possa esercitare
un'attrazione sulla luce stessa quindi
deformarne il cammino ma dobbiamo
aspettare un po di tempo perché questo
predizione di einstein sia realmente
osservata e nel 1919 ed hinton durante
un eclisse solare veramente conferma
osservativa mente quello che hassan
aveva premesso è previsto infatti grazie
al fatto che la luce del sole veniva
oscurata noi abbiamo le stelle tra la
posizione che ci aspettavamo quindi
senza questo effetto della deformazione
e che diciamo senza il lens in
gravitazionale quindi questa
deformazione del nostro lenzuolo e la
posizione delle stelle invece vera
osservata grazie all'effetto dell'ex in
gravitazionale è il tempo ci aveva detto
che in realtà in una ri in un calcolo di
modesto valore
questo effetto dell'en singh non poteva
essere osservato con le stelle perché
era un effetto piccolo non poteva mai
essere visto madri chi un po più tardi
nel 1937 all'intuizione ok va bene una
stella forse modifica poco il cammino
della luce ma se invece di una stella
noi ne mettiamo crew stelle se
utilizziamo una galassia quella che
tricky nel 1937 che ama nebula con una
nebula l'effetto lo possiamo osservare e
questa volta dobbiamo aspettare un po
più di anni ma finalmente nel 1979 walls
osserva osserva un effetto di lansing di
due oggetti che sono quasi stellari che
noi chiamiamo quasar e finalmente
vediamo le immagini di questi due quasar
per effetto dell'ente
ingranditi e moltiplicati eh già perché
questo fa una lente
guardate la terra da una parte
dall'altra parte molto distante rossa la
nostra galassia e al centro azzurra la
nostra lente che sta deviando e raggi
che provengono dalla galassia per la
deviazione di questi raggi cioè per la
deformazione di questo nostro lenzuolo
la luce fa un cammino curvilineo e in
modo apparente ed rivediamo l'immagine
della galassia rossa distante
moltiplicata è ingrandita e fa solo
questo
la lente no in realtà la lente non fa
solo una moltiplicazione è un
ingrandimento
ma fa anche qualcos'altro ecco guardate
questa è l'immagine della galassia cosa
le succede se ad attraversarla e una
lente e allora c'è un terzo effetto di
cui non ho parlato
cioè abbiamp la moltiplicazione abbiamo
l'ingrandimento abbiamo anche la
distorsione con un calice la una candela
vista attraverso la base di un calice
bene l'immagine di questa candela visto
attraverso la base di un calice viene
moltiplicata i pezzettini ingrandita ma
anche distorta e le molteplici immagini
possono anche unirsi a formare un solo
anello e beh guardate confrontate quella
che era la realtà di un immagine
l'alzata da una galassia che sta al
centro e quello che è l'immagine
similare del calice e quindi le lenti
che fanno allora le lenti stanno
moltiplicando stanno ingrandendo e
stanno distorcendo ma di quanto a questo
effetto ebbe l'effetto dipende dalla
lente quindi abbiamo bisogno di
conoscere la fisica e abbiamo bisogno di
conoscere la lente e la lente è solo una
stella o una galassia
no il nostro lenzuolo può essere
deformato un bel po e può essere
deformato per la presenza
sarà di un insieme di galassie
addirittura un ammasso beh in questo
caso i raggi vengono deviati parecchio e
grazie proprio alla distorsione da parte
di un ammasso di galassie quindi un
insieme di galassie che è finalmente nel
novembre 2014
quello che attendevamo veramente danni
che cosa è successo
osservando un ammasso di galassie
abbiamo visto un oggetto che era un
puntino particolarmente luminoso questo
puntino luminoso era visibile per ben
quattro volte ben quattro pulcini che
all'improvviso si sono accesi quindi
qualcosa di transiente la sua luminosità
all'improvviso aumentata era una
supernova ma non una supernova qualsiasi
una supernova esplosa in una galassia
del fatah che colpo di fortuna in questa
supernova l'abbiamo chiamata rascal
resta com'è il primo fisico che aveva
teorizzato la possibilità di comprendere
qualcosa di più importante all'interno
dell'universo le leggi fisiche
dell'universo attraverso gli oggetti
proprio questi oggetti transienti lenza
ti queste super no guardate cosa era
accaduto
e accaduto che il nostro lenzuolo dritto
venisse deformato dalla presenza
dell'ammasso di galassie sempre il
reticolo il nostro lenzuolo e i raggi
vedete quelli rossi provenienti dalla
galassia che sta dietro sono stati
deviati deviati sono arrivati fino a noi
in ben tre diverse immagini
un vero colpo di fortuna perché con un
opportunità unica potevamo riservare la
supernova per ben tre volte come un
cartone animato lo ri avvolgevano e le
loro affermavano e adesso la domanda
ok lo possiamo riservare tre volte ma lo
stiamo osservando l'ultima volta
possibile o siamo fortunati e cerchiamo
di capire perché è possibile ri
osservarla tre volte
perché i raggi partono allo stesso
istante ma abbiamo detto che vengono
curvati in modo diverso fanno cammini
diversi quindi possono arrivare in tempi
diversi
e allora che è arrivato prima bene
guardate 1 e questo raggio questo raggio
è molto lontano da dove nel suolo e
curvato e arriva subito ci è andata male
questo ce lo siamo persi è la supernova
esplosa già prima è invece due è lontano
dalla massa ma non così tanto
ed è quello presente quello che stiamo
osservando e allora abbiamo la fortuna
di avere tre perché il trend non è
ancora arrivato quindi il 3 e il nostro
futuro
quando arriva la supernova quando
possiamo rio osservare l'esplosione
della supernova entra ed ecco qui la
nostra grande opportunità gran team di
scienziati ognuno impegnato in questo
tipo di ricerca con i propri modelli con
i propri test della fisica da fare ha
cominciato a lavorare insieme
siamo partiti tutti dagli stessi dati
una grandissima comunità che tutte
insieme
lavorava per cercare di conoscere quello
che la scienza dovrebbe essere
condivisione e comprensione
un'esperienza unica che mi ha visto
felicissima di abbracciare questa sfida
abbracciare questa sfida per la
comprensione di quando esattamente la ri
osserveremo quando la ri osserveremo
dipende dipende da che cosa dipende dal
nostro modello preciso della lente e
della nostra conoscenza della fisica e
allora la lente che cos'è qui
qui la lente e questo ammasso di
galassie che vi ho fatto vedere prima
questa è l'immagine reale questo il
modello che ho costruito grazie alla
conoscenza della len
e grazie alla conoscenza della fisica
possiamo cercare di predire quando
possiamo riservare la supernova è il
nostro risultato è la supernova la
possiamo riservare nel 2015 futuro e
finalmente il nostro regalo di natale il
nostro personale regalo di natale il 16
dicembre il 16 dicembre del 2015
guardate questa è l'immagine della prima
supernovae le quattro immagini della
prima super nov
e qui non c'è niente ma il 16 dicembre
del 2015
ecco la supernova centrato punto
centrato è finalmente abbiamo potuto
riservare il futuro
e allora possiamo viaggiare nel tempo
ebbene sì possiamo viaggiare nel tempo
grazie alle lenti e non c'è bisogno di
avere un atteggiamento scettico un
atteggiamento preoccupato
basta abbandonarsi alla fisica le leggi
della fisica all'universo e due versi
questo viaggio grazie
[Applauso]